good after I managed to a platform for
engineering I have question for certain
particular a novela that housing it in
restoring laughing for research um at
the time it was a huge interesting
around 2001 2002 a huge interest in
carbon nanotubes so I was looking for
entering into this research area which
brought so many nice results but with
something new with some prime idea and I
thought why wouldn't we do something
like carbon nanotubes but flat instead
of rolled up and that led me to an idea
to to start making extremely thin pieces
of graphite I'm trying to make seen
pieces of graphite and studies and we
eventually went down to single layer of
graphite our lab has a specific way of
operation we have this so-called
frightening experiments when we try to
do very unusual things some chest sound
crazy ideas graphing was one of those
usually nine ninety percent of those
just don't work and you forget about
about them using day graphene would
extremely lucky that we were very
successful visit with with our very
first experiments on this material and
we continue working on it for the next
seven years
Oh